どうもみなさんこんにちは天才料理研究科
グリトングラ男でございます今日は誰でも
簡単に作れるちょっと大きいオムライスを
作っていきたいと思いますこれはもう
かなりスタンダードで誰でも簡単にいつで
も手頃に作れるのでぜひ皆さん真似して
作ってみてくださいというわけで材料の
紹介していきたいと思いますまずは卵
270個
鳥さんが産んでくれたとても新鮮な卵を
使用していますこれで美味しいオムライス
ができること間違いなしでしょう
ケチャップ40本ぐらいまあこれは正直
味付けの類になるのでもう気持ちの数だけ
ケチャップ準備していただいて健康で
ございます以下略です
というわけで早速ちょっと大きめな
オムライス作っていきましょう
[音楽]
というわけでまずは卵を割っていきたいと
思いますこれはもうオムライスのオムの
部分卵の部分になるのでかなり大事です
しっかり割っていきたいと思います持って
いきます
[音楽]
はい
卵無事全部割り終わりました
次は卵を混ぜていきたいと思います
[音楽]
たくさんの鳥さんたちの生命を感じますね
やっぱ全然混ざってない
量が多すぎるので2つに分けて混ぜていき
たいと思います
やばいいきますね全然
混ざってない
[音楽]
いい感じだこれでかなり混ぜやすくなった
ので混ぜていきたいと思います
皆さん見比べてみてくださいかなり
混ぜてないやつと混ぜた後色が相当違い
ますねただ多分こっちもまだ混ざりきって
ないので両方もうちょっと頑張っていき
たいと思いますそろそろ限界です
こっちは大丈夫だと思いますこっちも混ぜ
ていくよ
[音楽]
はいというわけで一応卵潰し終わりました
これでオフの部分は完成です次に行き
ましょうというわけで次に
鶏肉一口サイズに切っていきたいと思い
ますちょっとあのーかなり多いんですけど
も頑張って切っていきたいと思います
とっても時間がかかりそうじゃあ頑張って
切っていきたいと思います
[音楽]
鶏肉無事に切り終わりましたこれで一口
サイズですねはいというわけで次は玉ねぎ
を切っていきたいと思いますオムライスに
欠かせない大事な風味になりますので
玉ねぎ早速切っていこうと思います
どうやって切るんでしょうでも何か多分
最終的に機械に放り込むのでそのなんか
マシンに入る大きさに着るだけでいいです
[音楽]
[拍手]
はいというわけで
玉ねぎ切り終わりましたもうちょっと食べ
なきゃやるので切っていきましょうという
わけで適当に切った玉ねぎを機械を使って
さらに細かくしていきますじゃあ行きます
[音楽]
すげえ見ても一瞬でこれ
あとこの量か頑張ってやっていきます
[音楽]
目が痛いんだこれ
玉ねぎカットし終わりましたはいという
わけでかなり食材が揃ってきたので
いよいよ鍋の方に移りたいと思いますでは
行きましょう
フライパンかなこれはこれは何なん
でしょうねこのちょっと特殊なフライパン
で作っていきたいと思いますまずはバター
を切っていきましょうちょっと何個必要か
わからないんですけどもだいたい45個
ぐらい入れる準備しときますはい5個準備
しましたバター置きます
ごめんなさい
これを焦がさないように全体にまんべん
なく塗っていくんでしょうねこうやってる
うちにもう1個購入します
[音楽]
はいバターだいぶ溶けたので
玉ねぎ投入していきますナイスが50kg
あるので1回で全部作れないので2回に
分けて作っていきます玉ねぎいきます
パネルの優しくいきます
できたこれを
絡めていく感じになりますね玉ねぎをまず
しっかり炒めなきゃいけないので炒めて
いこうと思います
グッズを鶏肉も入れます
鶏肉も半分だからどれくらいだろう
[音楽]
ちょっと多すぎるかな失礼します
鶏肉もしっかり炒めていきましょう
塩コショウここで振っていきます
塩コショウ入れていきます
やばいどうしよう
[音楽]
えどれくらいどれくらいストップOKです
あとは焦げないように炒めていくぞ
[音楽]
なんかいい音してきた3つを通るまで
ちょっと待ちましょうお肉がしっかり出て
こないとガチの方でやばいんで水分が
ちょっと多かったかなと思うのでこれで熱
を通して水分を抜いていきたいですね
新しい武器です
あーでもだいぶ
肉に色がついてるだいぶ茶色っぽくなって
きてる
だいぶお肉に火が通ってきたのでそろそろ
ライス入れていきます20キロ20kg
いきますいきますよ
やばいちょっと待って跳ね返ってる
ビシャンてなったらどうしましょう
よしよしよし重てー
ヤバすぎる米の量がさらに10キロいき
ます行くよ行くよ行くよ
OkOk今
肉と
玉ねぎをスライスに絡ませながら
頑張ってほぐしてってます
だいぶ混ざってきたと思うので
ケチャップ入れていきますこっから俺の
加減ってことでしょ
ケチャップ入れてきます行くよお願いし
ます
[音楽]
いつ止めればいいんだとりあえず2本でも
使っちゃおう1回これで様子見ます
棒2本いきますいきますよ
[音楽]
行きます
白い部分をなくしたい
はいかなり全体的にケチャップが決まった
かと思います
[音楽]
ちゃんとうまいなんかケチャップあんだけ
かけてもちょっと薄いぐらいでしたね
結局オムライス作る時最後
ケチャップ自分でかけるので今ベストで
とりあえずこれを1回別のお皿に移します
はいというわけで最初にできたライスを1
回ボールに移して取っ手のお皿に入れて
いきたいと思いますでか100人分なので
このサイズになると思ってましたじゃあ1
回こっちに移していきます
[音楽]
さすがに一人でも作れないそして手伝って
もらっても作れない人数が足りないって
いうこの状況どうしようかというところで
まさかのあの日本屈指の天才料理研究家の
方お呼びしておりますどうぞ
[音楽]
どうも
川越シェフです
川越市に来ていただきましたよろしくお
願いしますちょっと1回やってみましょう
どんどん入れときます
[音楽]
1回これでお皿に移します
これはこういうのに下にお子様ランチ
みたいですせーのせーの
[拍手]
まあまあまあ上手いようまいうまい
[音楽]
では30キロのライスお皿に入れていき
ますお願いしますせーの
あっつやばい
みんな火傷だけしないようにお願いします
行きますねじゃあどんどん片付けて
ください出てきます
[音楽]
はいはいはいはいはいはいはいはい
温泉よしじゃあ形を整えます
はいというわけでライスの形ができました
あとは
卵をかけるだけです
卵をフライパンで焼く前に
牛乳を入れてふっくら焼き上がるようにし
ていきますどれぐらいだろうな
[音楽]
1本入れときますねよしオッケーです
じゃあ早速卵フライパンに乗せていき
ましょうではまず油を引いていきます油
ひきます
[音楽]
OKですので卵をぶっこんでいきたいと
思います
ひとすくい人すくい
[音楽]
はい移動できません
じゃあ行きますこれをまんべんなく伸ばす
感じですよねおそらく私は分かりませんが
はいはいはい
なんかもうちょい行けそうだな
あもうこれ完璧だ
完璧だこれこれでちょっとあのいけるか
どうかを確認しながら
ある程度固まったらもうします先生どう
ですか今のところこれ
今んとこいい感じです本当ですかポイント
とかあったら
是非教えて欲しいんですけれどはい気持ち
ですね
やっていきましょうかお願いします先生
ぜひ持ち上げてみていただいていいですか
[音楽]
液体をそうですか
お願いしますせーの
これをひっくり返すの無理なのでこう
スライドして落としますさあ行きますよ
[音楽]
本当にごめんなさいちょっとずつまずは
内角を攻めていきましょういきますね
よしよしよしよしよしだいぶ大きい
なるほど
はい1回目でこれぐらい乗せられました見
てください皆さんこれ後ろちゃんと綺麗に
なってるんですよ卵の色が真ん中こけてた
んでちょっと修正しながらもっと全部
卵かぶせていきたいと思います
[音楽]
うまそうOKです
敵
ました
ちょっとオムライスと言っていいかわかん
ないんですけどもやっぱり卵270個分を
このオムにするのがかなり難易度高くて
真ん中焦げたりしちゃってなかなか
バランスよく黄色いこういうオムライスに
するのが難しかったのでちょっと半熟オム
みたいな感じで102枚のオムライスで
完成しました
ケチャップかけてからが完成みたいな
ところがあるん
でください
[音楽]
皆さんかけすぎだと思ってるでしょう全然
そんなことないんです多分適量ですこれ
よし
[音楽]
はいというわけで味付けもできました
ケチャップとバジルみたいな乗せちゃって
本当にお店に売ってるような素敵な
オムライス
完成しました
大事なの味ですこれおいしかったらマジで
一人で全部食えますじゃあ早速食べてみ
たいと思いますこの辺じゃいただきますね
割とちゃんと作ったからマジで美味しいと
思うんですよね
ここら辺食べていきたいと思います
いただきます
[音楽]
焦げてるコーヒーの味がしますすごい
いただきます
[音楽]
うまいよかったちゃんとオムライスの味に
なってますこれ
[音楽]